sometimes everything in battlefield 2042
just clicks you and your squad each
playing different specialists work
together as a team and use your special
abilities to clear a building and
capture an objective
one drops a sentry turret another heals
teammates a third stands for hostiles
and the last grapples up to a perfect
position for an ambush moments like this
where the franchise's underlying
gameplay combined perfectly with new
ideas were my favorites in playing
battlefield 2042 during electronic arts
pre-release review event the game is at
its most fun when it brings new ideas
together with the franchise's
traditional feel playing the right
character with the right gun on the
right map at the right time elevates the
underlying competitive first-person
shooter framework that defines
battlefield
a lot of times battlefield 2042's
elements work well together but not
always battlefield 2042 steps out of the
shadow of past games in the franchise by
offering you the opportunity to play
specific specialists each with their own
special abilities and gadgets rather
than choosing from broader more generic
character classes of past games in our
time with battlefield 2042 there were a
lot of moments where having the right
specialist for the job felt great and a
few where some characters felt like the
wrong choice for the map they got to my
cover
it illustrates how the game can
sometimes struggle as developer dice
expands it away from its underlying
formula some specialists like the
wallhack enabled pike are useful on any
map as long as you can get close to
enemies others such as the resource
dropping angel often are a lot less
exciting or impactful still while some
ideas and characters don't necessarily
feel like they jive with everything
battlefield 2042 has to offer the game
takes steps forward that expand on what
already works about the franchise by
pushing you to play in different ways
specialists are the big new addition to
battlefield 2042 representing an
adjustment in the choices you make about
how you'll face off against other
players where battlefield previously had
squads composed of players taking on
different roles like medic assault
engineer or recon the specific
specialists you can choose from fill
those roles in 2042 so while multiple
characters might be considered support
or assault class specialists each is
distinct from the others it gives
battlefield 2042 a more hero shooter
feel taking pages from games such as
overwatch or rainbow six siege veteran
battlefield players might chafe at the
idea of hero shooter sensibilities
intruding on their military sim fps but
the addition of specialists in
battlefield 2042 is often one of its
highlights especially when working
closely with your squad having a variety
of specialists and knowing how to use
them well creates a lot of situations
where you can help each other out
battlefield is generally an fps best
enjoyed with friends utilizing
communication and teamwork and the ways
that different specialists can synergize
and support the group brings out the
team play experience in a lot of new
ways what's more playing with different
characters gives you vastly different
gameplay experiences flying around the
battlefield with a wingsuit as sundance
or zipping up to high ground as mckay is
pretty far removed from pushing toward
an objective with a riot shield as dozer
sprinting through fire to save a hurt
squatty as folk or setting up an ambush
with a sentry turret as boris
because of their different abilities and
uses each specialist brings their own
specific feel to battlefield 2042
offering you a lot of different kinds of
fun even in a single match as mentioned
the addition of specialists isn't always
perfect a few feel out of place or even
kind of useless on certain maps there's
also the constant shooter problem where
exciting characters that earn high kill
counts like peg with her ability to see
through walls for short periods will
undoubtedly draw more use than support
leaning or more stationary characters
like falk angel and boris but dice
promises to add more specialists in the
future and there's enough diversity of
gameplay experience in the cast already
that seeing additions and recombinations
and how they work together is an
exciting prospect while different
approaches to gameplay mostly come from
your choice of specialist they're
supported through battlefield 2042's
highly customizable gear loadouts your
kit comes with a primary gun and a
secondary sidearm as usual although now
you're able to use any gun with any
character there are generic loadouts for
each class which give you items like a
deployable medpack if you choose the
medic kit or a vehicle repair tool if
you choose the engineer kit but you can
also adjust these anytime that means
that just because your specialist is
designated as recon or support doesn't
mean you have to play them that way
allowing you to mix and match aspects of
different classes with specialists to
create a playstyle all your own having a
broad opportunity to adjust what gear
you're carrying even within a match is a
big plus in the quality of life column
for battlefield 2042 in addition to
loadout customization there's also the
new plus menu system which allows you to
set several attachments for your guns in
the loadout screen and then change them
on the fly as you play if you're headed
into some tight hallways you can quickly
swap your assault rifle's long range
scope for iron sights and toss on a
suppressor to cover the sounds of your
shots if you're facing a vehicle you can
trade out your anti-infantry rounds for
armor-piercing bullets the ability to
use any weapon at almost any time
combined with more customization for the
situation you're up against makes you
feel like both an important part of a
team with a specific job and a versatile
fighter ready for a variety of
situations
speaking of quality of life changes
there's nothing quite as nice as the new
call-in tablet that lets you summon a
vehicle from just about anywhere
battlefield is known for its huge maps
that take a lot of time to cross and
calling in a jeep or a tank almost
whenever you want is excellent
battlefield 2042 includes three
different types of competitive modes at
launch each offering surprisingly
different experiences although there's
no single player campaign this time
around the more traditional are the
all-out warfare modes breakthrough and
conquest both are about huge armies of
as many as 128 players attempting to
capture control points in various
sectors as they fight for victory
conquest remains as fans remember it
from past games with the goal being to
exhaust the enemy's respawn tickets by
killing opponents and capturing control
points the more points you capture the
more the opposing team bleeds tickets
conquest like in past battlefield games
can feel chaotic and haphazard with
players streaming in from all directions
at all times and plenty of opportunities
to get picked off by somebody you didn't
see that can be increased by battlefield
2042 feeding in occupying forces ai
controlled soldiers who fill out a
match's player roster if there are gaps
the ai bots are not especially smart but
they do help make matches feel like
enormous battles with a huge number of
combatants breakthrough on the other
hand is a more streamlined tuned version
of the experience one team attacks while
the other defends but only one sector is
active on a map at a time the attacking
team has to capture all the control
points in a sector in order to advance
to the next but they have limited
respawns with which to do so while the
defending team has infinite respawns
breakthrough is a bit like rush in
battlefield bad company 2 and feels like
a more action heavy straightforward game
type compared to conquest where you
always know roughly where the enemy will
come from and where the action will be
making huge maps feel less daunting
where conquest is a huge and free if
confusing experience breakthrough is a
smaller tighter and more predictable one
in both all-out warfare modes though it
often felt like battles came down to
which team was smarter and better at
using vehicles there are a couple of
specialists specifically equipped to
deal with vehicles but for the most part
tanks and wildcats still tend to roll
over players sometimes literally who
don't have many good options to deal
with them hopefully as players get more
used to the options in their loadouts
and the plus system the balance between
specialists and vehicles will even off a
bit more
[Music]
battlefield 2042's other modes hazard
zone and portal take a very different
attack from the more traditional
battlefield modes hazard zone is a
squad-based free-for-all mode that
borrows from battle royale but with a
more objective oriented flavor your
squad of four heads onto a map with the
goal of seeking out and pilfering hard
drives from crashed satellites capturing
drives earns you special credits you can
spend on your loadout between matches as
does killing opposing players and
occupying forces but to get the money
from the drives you need to reach an
extraction point and board a plane if
you die in the mode you're dead for good
unless a squad mate can survive long
enough to use an uplink device found on
the map to summon you back into the
fight hazard zone's mixture of battle
royale and free-for-all ideas makes it a
really standout experience particularly
when you add in the specialists unlike
in other modes your squad can only have
one of each specialist on it during a
hazard zone match so working together to
decide on a strategy and the abilities
to fit it is important where the all-out
warfare modes are huge and messy hazard
zone is a much more strategic and
close-knit experience and it works
beautifully with all the different
customization and specialization
elements at play in the game the
drawback of hazard zone is that winning
begets winning the more money you earn
in a match the better your chances of
being well outfitted in the next match
because you can use that money to buy
tactical upgrades like uplinks to save
your squad mates or faster health
regeneration for yourself money is also
necessary to buy anything other than the
base assault rifle pistol and grenade if
you want a sniper rifle you need the
funds to buy it and it will only last
for one match unlike battle royale games
though the slate isn't wiped clean with
every new match you're rewarded for
having done well in your last run so the
best players seem like they'll always
have funds to play with so they can
always run their favorite loadouts with
their favorite slate of tactical
upgrades while everyone else seems like
they'll be at a disadvantage
[Music]
finally there's portal which fills out
battlefield 2042's multiplayer match
offerings with seemingly endless variety
the mode allows players to create
matches and game types of their own
using a website editor and make them
available to the community to play the
editor is impressively robust portal
allows you to do easy things like change
the rules of a match so that players can
run faster or only use certain weapons
but there's also an in-depth logic
editor that lets you create much more
involved contingencies dice demonstrated
its capabilities by creating a rocket
launcher only match that required
players to jump up and down in order to
reload their weapons which led to some
ridiculous chaos as a pair of players
would miss each other with the initial
bout of explosives and descend on one
another in a desperate jumping knife
fight portal also opens up the options
by allowing you to mix elements from
battlefield 1942 bad company 2
battlefield 3 and battlefield 2042
together in matches the games have all
been streamlined somewhat to feel
similar to 2042 so there's parity
between forcing the soldiers of world
war ii on one team to fight those of the
near future on another still the mixing
of different games and their weapons
gadgets vehicles and classes means the
community can create a whole host of
different experiences the possibilities
add a ton of variety to battlefield
2042's offerings at launch which would
otherwise feel a bit thin with only
all-out warfare and hazard zone perhaps
the biggest draw though at least
initially will be the opportunity to
play 128 player battles on old
battlefield game maps with their
original classes weapons and rules
intact we ran through a smattering of
matches borrowed from the older games
and each brought a rush of nostalgia
with it as we played those battlefield
classics they notably lack some of the
quality of life improvements of
battlefield 2042 and a lot of portals
mixed up modes feel like they'll mostly
be good for laughs but like the
customization options and specialists in
the 2042 portion of the game portal
offers a bunch of new ways to expand on
the core battlefield experience what's
really impressive in battlefield 2042 is
the variety that's on offer it lets you
play a bunch of different kinds of fps
experiences in different game modes in
different portal rule sets and even in
the same match as you switch between
characters portal lets you relive the
battlefields of the past but on the 2042
side dice has cherry-picked from popular
trends like hero shooters and battle
royales the best part is that mostly it
has done a really effective job of
curating those additions so that they
bring more to what players already like
about battlefield rather than changing
what already works
[Music]
you